yes you didn't have anything else on you
I had the bike any crack in the car no
you smoked crack what's that yeah you
smoke the crack is that what happened no
no that was much much earlier I was
getting my hands out of my pockets
putting everything away just trying to
get earlier earlier when I smoked
earlier
in my house okay what's your name
and you're an attorney yes I'm the
council member France and you're a
councilman the prince yes I am
you're a councilman in Cranston smoking
crack with crack on you
what do you think the constituents would
say I know what I'm going to say but you
know I'm going to refrain from it but
I've been seeing for 13 years I went
through really bad the more season than
I did Relapse